CPAC is an annual gathering of american
conservative activists taking place this
year under growing tension with Moscow I
thought I find out what they thought of
President Putin he must be worsened that
Obama fellow right here's the worst
president oh that's a hard question for
both tyrant Obama i am and what I saw
this situation in the Ukraine with
President Putin yeah
well we can't do math severe drops like
we did in earlier here's the worst
president obama or Putin had to go
tomorrow it's a very close call I could
say that they would be a tie for last
place but he's a Western iza is it one
day only Western leaders many many would
say standing up some soda valleys yeah
who's worse President Obama or president
[ __ ] at this point as sad as this is to
say that questions very much up for
today is worse hate to make a choice
between Camille
yeah you like a manatee business with
President beauty how far along this map
does you have to get to you before
America says stop um gosh he's kind of I
don't know maybe Romania all right but
let them know right now the world is
laughing at America the world is
laughing at our president because they
do not take him serious who's was a
farmer all kitchen
Obama both equally destructive policies
Barack Obama should consider making
Vladimir Putin his defense secretary is
the worst president obama or putin his
people back him up low so he's got that
goal I mean I wouldn't I don't agree
with the guy but he's got this country
support well how would you stand up to
rush her again legal says it will soar
across America
thank you hooting things are worth the
worst president obama oh yeah certainly
certainly in my life do you think he's
worse than President Putin in Russia no
can't welcome now that's it that's
awesome thank you very much yeah very
anti-communist I can tell all right well
it's up this Americans for Prosperity
they're driving a Nissan lady from a
very small town in the hills of
Tennessee subscribes to spectate
newsletter every Labor
love it